This is a way to create visibility.
Especially, to show what I do,
in my case, in the dance field,
and what I've been learning
throughout the years.
This is my culture, I can confront it
and make it visible.
This way I can also work with people
that can help me to expand.
I also have the opportunity to go abroad
and work with people
from many different countries.
Through this Lab we can meet other artists
from different countries
and diverse backgrounds and skills.
We can share and see how do they do
and I can show my skills too.
How do you communicate using
the strength of each person.
Some people were sitting in a wheelchair
but it doesn't matter,
there are always possibilites
to work with the situation,
to work with a wheelchair,
to work with a person,
to work with the environment,
with everything you see,
everything that you can use
to make your piece.
It's very rare but also rich
to have such a diverse group together
during the artistic Lab this week.
And that means so much for
the development of all these artists,
their talent development.
And therefore, I think it's very important
that these artistic Labs are happening.
It helps every single one of them
to go back to their own place
and develop even further.
It's been about heightening
choreographers' senses, I would say,
and that's been quite key,
just sensing
what's going on in the space
and how you are working with your partner.
I think that's really important.
And what's really interesting
is it feels like this course is something
that every choreographer should do, actually.
It's something that everyone should practice.
I'm most interested when I see work
that's coming from
some new or strange or unexpected
perspective.
For me, this is the point of art.
That we reimagine how we're living,
what we care about, what we do.
And I think...
I can only speak from my own perspective,
but I think living in a world
with a very particular experience,
if the world makes you immediately question:
"does this have to be like this?",
"are there different ways?".
And so, I think all the artists at this Lab
are pushing the edges
of what is the expectation of their work,
what else is possible.
And I think that any artist who comes
with a very unusual perspective on the world
has a lot to offer
and makes the most interesting work.
For me, it's about individuals having voices,
and really strong voices,
and being present and not being ignored
nor sidetracked.
So, that's the key for me,
is that there are voices in the room
and they are being noticed.
And it's acceptable that they are different
and we celebrate the differences.